hello everyone and welcome to a truly uh
spectacular game from round seven of
this year's vhs olympiad it is a
weightless versus grand malcommy on
board two of the match united states
versus armenia and it is a game that
could very well decide the fate of the
entire olympiad or it might not but it
very well could
i don't want to spoil anything about the
game as it is it's i mean uh it's
completely out of this world you guys
will enjoy it uh let's dive straight
into it wesley so has the white pieces
and he opens with e4 uh meltman uh
decides to play c6 he goes for the karo
khan defense and already a slight
deviation by wesley he doesn't go for
the main line d4 he goes for knight to
c3 to give you an example of uh
how often this play for example b4 is
there are over 100 000 games
rated games in the database with this
move and regarding knight to c3 there
are
around a bit more than 10 000. so d for
uh pretty much everyone plays so it's
already a slight surprise with d5 by
malcolm young knight to f3 and the
bishop of the g4 pinning wesley's knight
we have h3 voiceless says all right what
are your plans with the bishop are you
going to move it to h5 or are you going
to capture it uh my knight on f3 so here
are melting captures with twin captures
and now pawn to e6 uh you've traded off
your lights for bishop and of course now
you put your pawns on light squares
that's a standard plan we have bishop to
e2 and the bishop to c5 now uh we have
castles by wesley and knight to d7 uh
and here the most common moves are queen
to g3 just going for that g7 pawn and
also b4 is a well-known move just
attacking the bishop and if the bishop
captures then of course the rook the b1
you go after the
not of course the b8 square but the b7
pawn and usually uh
you don't capture on b4 but here with
the goes for the immediate e captures on
d4 it's not new it has been played
before
uh c captures on d5 and now rook to d1
now preparing this d4 push with knight g
to f6 and now on to d4 and here there is
a game that reached this exact same
position it was played in croatia uh
here in my country uh i was played in
the croatian cup this year uh between
you uh yuri's established and robert
delta where bishop the v6 was played and
that game ended in a draw however here
we have bishop to e7 and it is now as of
move tender we have a completely new
game so what happens now okay wesley
plays bishop to d3 uh the bishop will
very nicely be
attacking the kings that you are
expecting the black king to castle king
side plus also the rook will return to
e1 so you don't want your own light
square bishop blocking it with castles
here and now the ship to f4 just nicely
continuing development and here malcolm
said all right you're wasting your time
improving the position of your pieces
i'm going to do the same and he goes
knight back to b8 he wants to shift the
knight over to c6 yeah so knights they
do wesley says all right i'm gonna waste
even more time to solidify my position
knight to c6 and now pawn to c3 adding
another defender to this pawn on d4 uh
rook to e8 and now rook back to e1 and
now point to g6 so just you know
improving the position a little by
little uh knights the g3 by wesley it's
not much but already you kind of do have
uh you know four attackers in front of
the black king maybe even five if you
consider rook honey one an attacker i
consider rook only one an attacker
because it can very easily be shifted
into the attack uh if you know the
position calls for it so here knight
to d7 now preparing this e5 move and if
you can execute e5 here with black you
will be completely fine here so wesley
goes for rook to e3 a nice rook lift now
the other rook can come to e1 and now we
have pawn to e5 and this is where a game
gets really exciting and where the game
really explodes uh wesley plays birchef
h6 and this is just incredible uh wesley
is inviting ponte e4 and uh what what is
this
uh it could be that uh wesley completely
missed this which would be very odd as
his was so world
world chess 960 champion uh but on the
other hand if it's not a blunder what is
it now what is wesley planning here so
here that e4 was played and e4 for
malcolm completely blunders the game and
but you know we can't really blame him
because what he missed here is
completely out of this world here wesley
plays rook captures on e4 and now that
you see it you of course believe it and
now
what what is rook to e4 now well what
the point of rook to e4 is
uh i i don't know if i even should say
it but the point is that if you capture
it then comes i'm not i'm not even going
to tell you what comes feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
move that wesley had in mind
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on sporting this
absolute brilliancy and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
queen capture sun f7 uh this movie is so
wild we are going to watch it one more
time in slow motion look at this queen
captures on f7 and now you don't have a
move if you move the king bishop g7 or
queen g7 is checkmate and if you accept
the queen sacrifice then bishop the c
for check and that's it look at the
bishop pair from hell there is nowhere
for the king to go to but forward king
f6 now comes knight captures an e4 with
check only move king f5 now comes g4
with czech sacrificing the knight after
the queen and after king captures on e4
now comes rook to e1 check king the f3
and now the spectacular bishop to d5
checkmate look at this bishop slicing
this way bishop slicing this way
uh i mean this is uh that you you you
simply don't see this uh very very often
in in top level chess in 2022 you know
especially in an elite tournament like
the olympiad so uh what uh you can do
here is just resign the game or you can
maybe try to mix it up a little bit so
here malcolm and of course decided to
mix it up he saw that it is impossible
to capture the rook otherwise just queen
sacrifice and checkmate so he played
knight to f8 but now he's just down upon
and it's way too easy for wesley to
organize a very powerful attack so rook
to f4 going after the f7 pawn we have
pawned the f5 but now wesley doesn't
even uh give a moment's rest for milkman
to you know recuperate his forces he
just goes knight captures on f5 so he
not counting anything not going for
material just you know
playing a brilliant brilliant game g
captures on f5 rook captures on f5
giving up the the piece for some pawns
here and now rook captures and d5 is
also coming so queen to d6 putting
pressure on the dark square bishop here
but now queen g4 check
knight to g6 and now of course rook
counters on d5 now the queen cannot
capture the rook we have uh queen the
air queen has them also queen to f6 now
hoping to get queen to h4 and maybe
trade queens but wesley just plays g4 he
says i'm not letting you off the hook uh
at all uh bishop to f8 offering a trade
of bishops and now rooked at five
attacking the queen queen to e7 and now
finally the bishop assumes the diagonal
that it was always meant to assume uh
bishop c for check king they chat and
bishop g5 and he was in this position on
move 28 that frank malcolm resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here uh such a such a spectacular game
the point is after the queen moves for
example queen to d6 or wherever you can
just play not that obviously you can
play rook f6 attack the queen and once
the queen moves again because there
really aren't all that many squares for
the queen now comes rook f7 and once the
queen moves again rook captures on h7
this is one way to checkmate the black
king king captures queen h5 check king
g7 and now queen to h6 will be checkmate
so that's one way to do it uh but pretty
much whatever else you play just loses
the game on the spot so this is truly
truly a remarkable game by west is so
the world official random champion
uh but what i find even more interesting
about this game is that
i don't think this uh came as
preparation i think this uh came uh you
know just uh for from wesley's uh
i mean
spectacular
uh
control over the over any position uh
because here after this bishop the h6
move was played uh e4 is good for black
or rather e4 isn't good for black right
away but it is good for black if you
throw in a certain move and there is a
certain move that malcolm could have
played here that would make things uh
very very difficult for wesley and that
move is bishop to f8 it's a move that
you will not find over the board much
like malcolm young did not find even in
a classical game but just to show you
guys bishop to f8 and now uh all of the
tactics that worked
in the game no longer work
because now once you capture an f8 now
we just play e4 that's the whole point
and now it doesn't matter what you play
uh one option is to just continue
attacking knight captures on e4 and now
after pawn captures we're going to play
knight characters first bishop captures
an e4 knight characters on f8 and now
rook 81 and the wesley would have
some very nice compensation for the
sacrificed piece he would have seven
pawns and milkman would have five pawns
but uh uh still with with perfect play
or even with uh decent play black should
not have any problems here and another
thing you could do after e4 is play
queen back to b1 if you don't want to
sacrifice any pieces then we just trade
rook characters and f8 you move your
bishop that's under attack and now for
example f5 but still with this beautiful
expansion black should be better for the
rest of the game so uh after wesley's
bishop to h6 i consider it a brilliancy
because bishop to f8 is a move you
simply do not find over the board uh
as was the case here but after that
after going for e4 uh then the game just
explodes oh of course and like i said
you cannot blame milk i mean who would
who would think that the queen captures
an f7 is the idea
i mean
not not right away but
obviously after you know rook captures
on e4 if you accept wing captures on f7
the game just falls apart it's uh we we
have to see it one more time bishop c
for checking f6 knight captures king f5
knight sacrifice king captures and now
of course rookie one f3 and bishop b5
checkmate uh we are going to end the
video with this with this position as a
suggester i i i i'm
uh you know i'm i'm very happy that i
was uh you know around to see this game
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh after this game uh ward
one completely exploited the sergio and
realized that he has to go and play for
a win against fabiano corona so we'll
see what happens in the other boards but
as wesley won his game extremely quickly
the other boards had to
play much more aggressive against the
other members of the united states so
we'll see what happened there as well
so once again really hope you guys
enjoyed this spectacular queen sacrifice
by the world official random champion uh
i would like to thank derek king felix
doctor christian what about him casey
vance and braxton reynolds for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
olympiad
until it finishes so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day